february 27th was a noteworthy day for
this ansonov an-124 cargo plane it had
just delivered three million coved rapid
antigen tests to toronto's pearson
airport and after the russian army
destroyed the antonov 225 the largest
cargo plane in the world the an-124
became number one by default
oh and that was also the day this
particular plane was grounded
indefinitely in toronto
you see three days after the invasion
canada like many other countries closed
its airspace to russian aircraft a
ministry of transport spokesperson says
this measure is in effect until further
notice so the massive antonov can
technically leave the country it just
can't fly
this thing's a big paperweight now
aviation lawyer bill clark was hired by
an unnamed canadian cargo company
looking to help ukraine by keeping the
plane out of the war despite russian
claims it's a commercial aircraft
baloney
we even use them for military purposes
what the distinction is
that they're trying to make is that
they're not registered as military
aircraft but they're utilized all the
time clark makes no bones about his role
it's to money the waters using the law
if the no-fly zone is lifted he'll argue
the plane hasn't been maintained or the
russian owner volga de nipper hasn't
paid its bills and parking at pearson
isn't cheap 1065.60
per day for a total of 138 thousand
dollars
and counting
the one thing clark won't do work for
the russians
i have had overtures through
two different foreign countries
for our legal firm to act on behalf of
the russian operator and we said kiss
off
and good luck in finding anybody in
canada that's going to help you so if
you're driving by pearson airport and
spot the largest cargo plane in the
world don't stop in the hopes of seeing
it take off
it could be here a while
like global news toronto